bonjour et merci de nous avoir rejoints
dans fit l'écho ce magazine est
consacrée à la reconversion
professionnelle d'après une étude tns
sofres réalisé l'année dernière
57% des salariés tous secteurs confondus
souhaitent se reconvertir
avant la fin de leur vie professionnelle
nous rencontrerons christian et jean
françois
tous deux ont fait le choix de changer
de métier ils nous raconteront leur
histoire
mais tout d'abord nous allons retrouver
ce qu'on peut appeler un spécialiste de
la reconversion
suivez-moi christophe robin bonjour je
vous êtes directeur d'asco va en centre
de bilan de compétences basé à montilly
votre rôle est donc d'aider des
personnes à faire un bilan sur leur
carrière et de les aider dans leur
projet professionnel
finalement quels sont les facteurs qui
amènent ces personnes à venir vous voir
alors trois grands types de facteurs les
amène le premier économique lorsque les
personnes ont perdu leur emploi et
qu'elle cherche à se repositionner dans
l'activité économique le deuxième
lorsqu'elles ont une lassitude dans
leurs fonctions lorsqu'elles souhaitent
évoluer lorsqu'elles ont fait le tour de
leurs activités et puis la troisième
lorsqu'elles sont confrontées à une
maladie ou à une difficulté de santé
dans leurs fonctions ou à une fatigue
alliant ces cas là elles vont venir me
voir pour essayer de trouver une
solution pour se reconvertir ces
personnes qui viennent vous voir pour
des raisons différentes
est ce qu'elles ont toutes une chance de
réussir leur reconversion
alors quand elles viennent nous voir
elles vont avoir une chance sur deux de
réussir leur reconversion s'ils ne
viennent pas nous voir si ça sécurise
pas leur projet de reconversion elles
ont toutes les chances d'échouer à plus
de 80% ce qui lie à un âge limite à la
reconversion
alors non il n'y a pas d'âge limite à la
reconversion la majeure partie des
candidats qui viennent nous rencontrer
vont avoir entre 35 et 45 ans 50 ans
maximum
donc au delà de 50 ans aujourd'hui
compte tenu de l'éloignement de l'âge de
la retraite on peut malgré tout se
reconvertir notamment lorsqu'on est sur
des métiers à forte pénibilité et où il
ya la nécessité de par la contrainte
santé de pouvoir évoluer ou pour changer
de fonction maintenant delattre
entendront de sade 35 ans il arrive
parfois que les candidats viennent nous
voir mais c'est plutôt rare et c'est
suite à des erreurs d'orientation
d'aiguillage
leur cursus scolaire pour ce fils échos
nous avons rencontré deux personnes qui
ont passé le cap qui ont réussi leur
reconversion
christian et jean françois je vous
propose de les retrouver pour qu'ils
nous racontent leur histoire on se
retrouve juste après christian mathieu
bonjour bonjour clair vous la
reconversion ça vous parle puisque vous
êtes aujourd'hui dans le transfert vidéo
mais vous avez changé de secteur 4 fois
dans votre vie
c'est exact vous avez commencé avec un
bagage d'électrotechnicien vous nous en
parler
oui alors j'ai une formation électro
technique bepc ap et mon premier
parcours professionnel l'a été avec
trois mécaniciens à la série de the
alstom à nancy et cela pendant sept ans
vous avez évolué dans ce poste oui tout
à fait vers un poste d'agent technique
assez et mesure où je m'occupais des
essais des moteurs mais finalement ça ne
vous convenait pas vous avez souhaité
changer de secteur partir dans le
commercial
oui on m'a fait prendre conscience donc
ma compagne de l'époque qui est devenu
mon épouse que j'avais d'autres
capacités et je me suis lancé dans une
carrière commerciale à qu'est ce que
vous avez fait comme vous avez débuté
alors la toute première carrière était
chez hachette où j'ai fait du porte à
porte pendant six mois mais qui est très
difficile mais j'ai appris énormément et
au bout de six mois
on m'a dit christian tu perds ton temps
donc j'ai tenté d' aventure sur paris
j'ai rencontré une société dans la foi
matic et j'ai démarré sur ainsi comme
informatiques en 1987 alors là encore
une fois des évolutions au fur et à
mesure des années oui puisque j'ai été
embauché en tant que technico commercial
et j'ai évolué vers un poste d'ingénieur
commercial et ensuite j'ai pris la
direction commerciale d'une entreprise
alors à ce moment-là qu'est ce qui vous
poser comme question pourquoi changer à
nouveau puisque vous avez quand même un
poste assez important à ce moment là
alors le changement s'est fait également
par un une succession d'entreprise dans
lesquels je travaillais qui ont été
rachetés par des plus grosses structures
et à chaque fois je vais été confronté à
rester dans l'entreprise ou partir et
j'ai connu le licenciement également à
une certaine époque et donc je me suis
posé la question j'avais 36 ans je me
dis qu'est ce que tu peux faire à 36 ans
et là j'ai fait en deux mois mais ma vie
dans de compétences et je me suis dit la
formation c'est quelque chose qui te
plaît donc j'ai démarré une nouvelle
carrière dans la formation
là c'était plus parce que le secteur
n'était plus porteur au niveau du
commerce
mais comment rentrer dans un nouveau
secteur sont finalement rien y connaître
j'ai répondu tout simplement à une
annonce au départ d'une entreprise qui
recherchait des consultants formateurs
gimat rendez vous et ce qu'ils ont
apprécié c'est ma personnalité mon
expérience bien que je n'avais pas
d'expérience concrète sauf une formation
que j'avais fait en 1995 une formation
de formateurs là quand même ils vous ont
demandé de renforcer cette formation
tout à fait je vis des cours oui donc là
j'ai été formé par l'entreprise dans
tout ce qui était développement
personnel et formations liés au
comportement talent c'est quelque chose
qui a été payé par votre société
absolument ça se passait bien ça se
passait très bien
et finalement vous choisissez encore une
fois de changer de secteur
oui j'ai encore changer au bout de
au bout de sept ans et l'a également bon
c'est un concours de circonstances qui a
fait que je voyais quelqu'un qui habite
et proche de chez moi avec une petite
voiture transfert vidéo et je me dis
tiens je vais pas rester dans le secteur
de la formation
cette fois j'ai envie de tenter
l'aventuré pour mais même en discutant
il m'a appris que la société pourrait
être à vendre
j'ai mis un an pour étudier et je me
suis lancé dans transfert vidéo niveau
fignon si vous n'avez pas eu d'elle par
contre vous avez cette formation de
formateurs est également là pour votre
métier actuel vous avez choisi de faire
une formation de monteur oui j'ai fait
une formation pour apprendre les
différentes technologies dans le domaine
audio vidéo est également la possibilité
de pouvoir faire du montage par rapport
aux prestations qu'on proposait vous ne
parliez au début de votre femme c'est
finalement quelqu'un que vous apportez
c'est important d'avoir quelqu'un qui
croit en vous c'est le plus important
parce que si vous n'avez pas le soutien
familial vous ne pouvez pas réussir est
comme ça n'a pas été tous les jours
facile il fallait véritablement que je
puisse obtenir ce soutien et de mon
épouse et mon fils la crise temps si
vous voulez bien on va voir maintenant
votre métier actuel est bien avec
plaisir allons-y
christian mathieu on retrouve dans votre
atelier
alors en quoi consiste ce métier de
transfert vidéo à l'activité elle est
très simple vous avez aujourd'hui des
personnes qui ont des vieilles cassettes
vidéos ou des vieux films 8 et super 8
et qui n'ont pu mater ray pour le
regarder donc nous votre métier consiste
à les transférer et elle est donnée sur
dvd ça marche ça marche très bien
ça marche très très bien vu et
finalement les expériences que vous avez
accumulé tout au long de votre parcours
professionnel vous servent aujourd'hui
oui chaque l'expérience était utile et
enrichissante
la première c'est la partie technicité
donc tout cet aspect technique de
formation initiale m'a aidé à mieux
appréhender cette activité ensuite la
partie commerciale
je suis amené à démarcher des
entreprises partenaires pour leur
proposer transfert vidéo la partie
formation puisque régulièrement s'il
faut informer former les personnes et
leur expliquer ce qu'est la technologie
aujourd'hui vous avez 52 ans vous êtes
chef d'entreprise vous avez deux
salariés vous avez encore envie de vous
reconvertir ou là ça y est c'est votre
dernier métier je dirais pas que c'est
mon dernier flétri envie de me
reconvertir non je n'y ai pas pensé
et par contre je ne l'exclus pas mais là
il ya encore des années à expérimenter
toute l'activité transfert vidéo si vous
aviez des conseils à donner à des
personnes qui souhaiteraient se lancer
dans l'aventuré se reconvertir les quel
serait-il
alors c'est tout à fait possible le
premier 1 c'est d'être soutenu ça c'est
impératif de de croire réellement dans
son projet d'être bien accompagné
et surtout d'avoir quand même plusieurs
casquettes à son arc puisque se lancer
dans une entreprise demande des
compétences techniques des compétences
de gestionnaire des compétences
commerciales et des compétences
comptables mais c'est possible et tout
le monde peut y arriver
christian mathieu merci beaucoup nous
avons aussi merci claire direction
chevreuse sur ce chantier nous
retrouvons jean françois lui aussi est
ce qu'on peut appeler un reconverti il y
a encore dix ans il était commercial
dans la grande distribution un poste
bien différent de son métier actuel je
vais 30 ans puis à 30 ans on a on sent
encore les ailes un petit peu poussé et
aujourd'hui j'ai quitté le bureau et je
suis descendu sur le terrain pour faire
de la menuiserie pvc bois et aluminium à
ce changement de vie était presque une
nécessité
pas facile à l'époque d'avoir du temps
pour ses deux enfants
et puis jean françois se sont jetés sur
la sellette dans sa société
si aujourd'hui il passe beaucoup de
temps au bureau pour gérer son
entreprise il a dû dans un premier temps
se former sur le terrain et tout
apprendre de ce secteur qui lui était
inconnu
lorsque j'ai quitté mon poste j'avais
prévu de quitter le costume trois pièces
et de deux passes et d'enfiler le bleu
de travail donc je suis allé poser
pendant plusieurs mois avec une personne
qui était déjà qualifié donc j'ai appris
l'été différentes techniques de pose des
amis qui travaillait dans ce secteur lui
ont appris les ficelles du métier et
l'ont aidé à étudier le marché et au
début il a fallu s'accrocher pour
pouvoir me lancer et puis arrivé disons
en vivre je pense que j'ai fait ce que
tout le monde une petite année de galère
voilà alors il ya des galères c'est quoi
c'est énormément d'heures travaillées
avec pas forcément le salaire qui
correspond
mais on apprend aussi à le plus
être en face de la fiche de paye le
nombre d'heures travaillées et c'est
quelque chose en fait qui fait que l'on
n'a plus du tout le même stress et puis
on est contents se lever le matin parce
que c'est devenu plus une passion qu'un
travail qu'il faut faire tous les jours
pour avoir juste une paye quoi apporter
son savoir-faire pour équiper des
logements plus écologiques ou encore
transformer cette maison rien qu'en en
changeant ses fenêtres son travail est
devenu synonyme de plaisir une passion
qui a porté ses fruits
jean-françois emploie aujourd'hui quatre
salariés et enregistre un chiffre
d'affaires de 600 mille euros est ce pas
probants nous sommes de retour avec vous
au centre de bilan de compétences
asko va donc par ces parcours de
christian et jean françois on voit que
les chemins sont variées pour changer de
métier ou de statut alors est ce qui
finalement il y a une démarche de type
alors il n'ya pas de démarche type
chaque chaque candidat peut essayer
d'évoluer ou de se reconvertir selon son
souhait ceci étant compte tenu du
dispositif qui finance la reconversion
notamment lorsqu'il s'agit d'engager une
formation il est préférable en amont de
pouvoir sécuriser son projet s'il ya une
solution qui peut être une bonne
solution c'est de commencer par un bilan
de compétences qui a permet de faire
l'inventaire des compétences de la
personne et qui va lui permettre ensuite
se projeter sur les différentes
solutions et avant même d'aller vers un
nouveau métier d'essayer d'identifier
les différents freins ou les différentes
difficultés qui pourraient survenir dans
le cadre de leur nouvelle orientation
donc en ayant anticipé ces éléments là
s'ils ont suffisamment préparés ils vont
pouvoir rentrer plus logiquement dans la
fonction définitive ou de leurs
fonctions futures
la suite logique c'est la formation la
suite logique ça peut être la formation
souvent les personnes en reconversion
vont partir d'un acquis et vont essayer
de transformer cet acquis en
capitalisant sur une partie des
compétences transversales et en
accumulant de nouvelles compétences pour
aller vers une nouvelle fonction une des
difficultés complémentaire c'est qu'il
faut accepter de repartir à zéro
tout à fait c'est exactement ce qui se
passe c'est à dire une fois que la
formation était suivi ou les nouvelles
compétences ont été acquises il faut
accepter doivent d'être à nouveau un
débutant repartir dans l'entreprise en
étant débutant c'est pas quelque chose
de simple ni facile d'accepter
psychologiquement khl et puis un
deuxième aspect c'est que derrière ce
caractère débutants souvent s'associe
une rémunération qui va relever aussi de
la rémunération du débutant et ça
été suffisamment anticipé ça concourt à
l'échec merci beaucoup son prix avant de
se quitter on regarde ensemble l'agenda
nous avons sélectionné deux dates autour
de la reconversion
une réunion d'information pour découvrir
les formations diplômantes
si vous souhaitez vous ouvrir de
nouvelles perspectives professionnelles
une meilleure rémunération ou une plus
grande mobilité
c'est ouvert à tous demandeurs d'emploi
étudiants ou salariés
rendez vous donc le 20 mars à la cité
des métiers à trappes
et puis la cité des métiers propose
également d'en apprendre un peu plus sur
le dif le droit à la formation et
notamment sur le dif portable on vous
expliquera sous quelles conditions les
chômeurs ou les nouveaux salariés
peuvent profiter de leur dif acquis dans
des précédents d'emplois cette matinée
d'information aura lieu le 25 mars
c'est la fin de ce fil est qu merci de
nous avoir suivi on se retrouve pour un
nouveau numéro le 22 mars